look how i feel whenever i [ __ ] t
from starbucks i'm like i feel like i'm
doing something wrong
oh i didn't even know you could do that
yeah you caught your kids
oh you can buy tsr bugs who buys tea at
starbucks
some of them are okay actually but i i
used to feel like now it's a bit more i
feel like tea has become more mainstream
and like i feel like it's it's a fashion
statement i feel like 10 years ago
coffee was like the thing it was like
everyone just
this is a weird thing but in starbucks
it was all about coffee coffee coffee
now it's all like everyone's chilled out
you can get over a [ __ ] t
no one gives a [ __ ] now this is a weird
statement
sometimes i make a point and i know this
is going to be a really hard battle
to not look weird i just i just went
through that five minutes ago
it's more like i don't go to starbucks
enough to
be like oh there's a new trend coming in
here ladies and gentlemen it's tea
now no i just i just remembered that
like i feel like i got mocked when i
ordered tea one time at a starbucks
what but who uh by my maybe my
classmates when i was like 15 i ordered
a tea and they were like
at starbucks men drink coffee connor
yeah yeah
no because like i i feel like it's more
back then
why would you go to starbucks for
anything but a coffee or coffee yeah
you don't feel like it i feel like
that's what it was back then and now
everyone doesn't really give a [ __ ] you
can get what you want
i mean i i would feel in england
especially you get a t you get a c
[ __ ] anyway it's [ __ ] england
everyone
every one of their drinks i think i
think that's what it is it's more like
you could get a tea anywhere so why did
you get it
yeah but you know back back when i
worked at the bbc
okay there it is there it is
[Music]
no but uh yeah back when i worked in the
office you know ev everyone would uh
every so often like the newbies or like
the interns or the graduates
they were always on t duty and i was
like that one person
in my entire team of like 20. i'm just
like
uh actually can i get a coffee please
literally everyone and everyone around
me drank tea ever that's that's what
everyone drinks
and all the interns scoffed at
coffee coffee what's that we're in
england
the uk is weird because like i think
most british people don't even drink any
other
type than english breakfast tea yeah
like i think most people
from the uk if you ask them i want a cup
of tea they would not ever even consider
anything else
other than like they didn't specify the
type of tea well that's a thing in the
uk if you ask for a cup of tea you're
getting spread just a
pg i didn't even know it was called
english breakfast i i yeah i
i just knew it was it's tea yeah yeah we
have brands right so we have friends in
the uk when you say i want a tea you get
the same type of tea yeah right unless
you specify
all right dude if you if you sit there
in someone's house and you're like oh i
want a tea and they're like oh do you
have like green tea or like some chai
they'd be like
no no that's that's exactly yeah really
yeah yeah yeah so if i came into your
house in the uk and i said
no no because because if you want a
different kind of tea you have to
specify yeah but
then most houses i don't think most
houses have other types of so i went
into a house and just said can i have
some chamomile tea
chamomile tea what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] is
that we just have tea
i feel like those types of teas are like
almost like luxury teas in the uk yeah
because
they always come in like fancy packaging
because like the british type is like it
comes in like
500 pack because that'll last you one
month in the uk yeah yeah
like you've got a family as well like
that yeah everyone in your family is
drinking tea so this is like when
americans ask me that i'm kind of tea
drinking connor it's like well
it's like i have a tea and then i have
like a an afternoon tea which
i do you know you drink like you try
everything you try the old grays you try
the other types
but if i'm drinking tea i have english
breakfast in the morning no
no no all day all day all day but it's
called english breakfast it's all day
yeah but it's
it's you people just drink it as like
like they drink coffee
it's it's like uh yeah but did i call it
morning coffee no no
it's like old gray or whatever it's like
the type of the t-shirt
part of british culture you know you
need to chill out you just chill out
with a cup but i realized how strange it
was when going to america it's like
that's not at all how it is no it's like
americans don't drink tea anyway
i think they do but again like if you
order these other people yeah if you
ordered
you know how i know americans don't
drink tea why because have you seen
their [ __ ] kettles
that's true that's true like like no no
culture
that drinks tea is built around the
[ __ ] kettles that the americans use
like
kind of kettles or americans oh there's
just these terrible things that these
awful things that can hold like
maybe 500 mils not even enough cups for
two people
yeah you got to put it on the stove
right oh those ones you put it on the
stove
and as a brick i'm like [ __ ] the heat
efficiency of this is giving me clinical
depression
what the [ __ ] is this i'm just like you
know you know when
when i go to someone's house in the uk
and they start doing that [ __ ] i'm like
what are you doing come i'll tell you
the one
thing that gave me a [ __ ] brain
aneurysm as someone who doesn't even
drink tea right
so huh i i drink i'm mostly a coffee
drinker
i'm i'm most i'm mostly a cough i'm
mostly a coffee drinker let me tell you
about tea
this thing i don't know about the thing
i don't know i don't i don't drink
english breakfast tea a lot of times i i
i drink green tea
i was like fancy [ __ ] right now
wow i mean i'm drunk
you're better than a working man i would
say
i'd say the amount of tea selection in
asia just [ __ ] eclipses whatever we
have in england
i mean come on we have that tea you just
you just don't order it you have to go
you have to go to the store manager be
like can you can you unlock the safe
is the other variation
you have to like move all the other teas
in the aisle to the back so you can grab
these things
yeah exactly i mean you go to if you go
to a [ __ ] company it's like opening
pandora's boxes of tea
you know you've got you got an entire
[ __ ] selection and then in england
you go like what you got like lipton
iced tea
that's pretty that's i don't even count
that as a [ __ ] time to be fair in the
combini
in japan it is like here's the 59th
version of green tea
and it's like you literally can't make i
don't even actually think it's
chemically possible to do 59 variations
of green tea
how much molecular like division are we
doing today there's these bonds here
it's just like leaves they picked from
like the 59th flight field yeah
it's absurd like and all the half of
them take the sh the [ __ ] doesn't
matter
okay like this t which is like i don't
even know what the [ __ ] this is
yeah you can live in japan for five
years and try trying new tea different
days it's [ __ ] easy
i've tried most of them yeah you've
tried every japanese
you're right i could confirm that half
of them taste exactly the [ __ ]
yeah and there was also like you know in
japan they had like
low low fat green teas or healthy green
teas and i'm like green tea is healthy
what do you mean
like it's something what are the it's
like it's just greasy have calories no
no it
doesn't no it doesn't but there's like
healthier low calorie creams well it was
like there was like
it was like good health green tea and
i'm like green tea is i actually think
one of the healthiest teas of all the
tea
yeah it is so what do you mean like what
have they done to the other teas
guys i can do one better i got an idea
zero calorie
water
by drinking it you lose calories yeah
but
yeah i just going back to the whole
thing i just get very amazed that like
you know because americans always ask
people from other countries like what
tea do you drink you know i drink
they're like i drink earl grey i drink
this it's like i don't know in the uk
it's not like that at all
like that's not how it works are you
sure that's just not like your household
no no no that's it's all over the uk you
go anywhere you want a cup of tea you
get it like
yeah no matter where you're going it's
only in the uk where if you say tea
it means one type of tea right and i
just always thought that's tea that's
just yeah
yeah i'm sorry every other c is just
like the branded tea right i guess it's
the same in japan as well like if you go
to
someone's household and you ask for ocha
which is tea
tea yeah like the default skin it's also
weird like the lengths that british
people would go to
to bring tea with them or like have a
cup of tea available
like i remember like uh you know when we
went whenever you go like camping or
an expedition i remember there was a guy
when we did like duke of edinburgh
who he like he drove
uh a car around to keep up with us but
in this thing there was just a whole
like massive hot water tank just for tea
so that we could all have tea okay you
know and i didn't think of that as weird
yeah yeah so that we could all have a
cup of tea when we were done yeah
because that's the british people that's
how you signify that working yeah
yeah like whenever we went paintballing
in the uk or anything like that
during the break you get tea yeah if you
read like [ __ ]
warfare and it'd be like stop chaps time
for the t-birds
you go for a tea break
and now that i think about this out loud
it's so weird but i'm like yeah we go to
like no matter what you're doing in the
uk
someone is going to try and put a cup of
tea available yeah
the stereotype is totally true it is it
is totally true like the best analogy i
can think of is that
to britain's to brits a cup of tea is
like the equivalent to like a cigarette
break
right it's just it's just an excuse to
like put on the kettle
like yeah like drink a bunch of tea and
just chill out for like five minutes
we have those in australia we don't know
we don't have tea breaks we have smokers
smokers
all right let's go